el ministro de defensa informó que mil
295 migrantes cruzaron el canal de la
mancha esto es una cifra récord en tan
solo un día desde 2018 las personas
cruzan en condiciones precarias y en
estas embarcaciones inflables poniendo
en riesgo su vida para llegar al puerto
de dover en la costa inglesa el día de
ayer entre ellos habían niños y bebés
que estaban envueltos en cobijas y
fueron trasladados a tierra y esto es un
problema creciente tan sólo en lo que va
del año han hecho el cruce 22 mil
personas esto es casi el doble en
relación al mismo periodo del año pasado
y los analistas consideran que la
política del gobierno para disuadir a
los migrantes que vengan a este país o
de lo contrario son enviados a ruanda no
está funcionando y serán uno de los
grandes retos del próximo gobierno que
será anunciado el próximo 5 de
septiembre
el creciente cruces de migrantes y
legales de francia hacia inglaterra en
condiciones precarias y que ponen en
peligro su vida el gobierno señaló que
ha arrestado a 38 traficantes después de
este cruce el día lunes que rompió un
récord y no tiene precedente